tonight's midterm election preview takes
us to Arizona President Trump is not on
the ballot there of course but he is a
big part of the conversation about a
very contentious Senate race chief
correspondent Jonathan hunt reports from
Phoenix though he's doing great the
specter of President Trump looms large
in Arizona's critical Senate race
I'll stick with him to the end I'm not
going to desert him no matter what
happened I was winning from the
beginning I'll be with him to the end
former Maricopa County Sheriff Joe
Arpaio controversial and immigration
hardliner
recipient of Trump's only presidential
pardon is the best-known of the
Republican candidates this is a
state-wide race with national
consequences but he faces stiff
competition from congresswoman martha
mcsalley form a fighter pilot preferred
candidate of the GOP establishment
critic of trump the candidate supporter
of trump the president I'm working with
him to support our military to secure
our border to grow our economy and a
fight for American values the American
people and this Kelly Ward former state
senator the conservative favorite before
Sheriff Joe jumped in she's optimistic
the Republican base will rally round her
they're seeking out thoughtful
conservative intelligent solutions for
the problems that are facing us and so I
think they are ultimately going to be
the ones that give the most important
endorsement and send me to Washington
but rallying the base could conceivably
make it harder for whomever wins the
Republican primary in August to win the
general election in November in a state
traditionally Republican that's changing
quickly in large measure because of its
growing Hispanic population well Arizona
is really on a tipping point politically
it's not the same Arizona as our
grandfathers and our grandparents the
winds of change are really with us
congresswoman Kyrsten Sinema
who declined our request for an
interview is the leading candidate on
the Democrat side I'm actually running
for US Senate and there's Deidre Abood a
former member of the Council on
american-islamic relations she hopes her
grassroots campaign
we'll make the difference out in the
field I'm actually meeting with people
I'm at an event one two six events every
day have been since April and while it's
a sensitive subject to raise it is worth
noting that given Senator John McCain's
health issues there is always the
possibility of not just one but two
Senate races here this year
Brett Jonathan Honda in Arizona tonight
Jonathan thank you